you
hi everyone is cherrymon chest calm and
I just got paired up playing now a 3-2
game so well this is different
II alia can defense I know I'm
butchering that pronunciation but uh
alright let's get some development and
I'm not gonna go for this chasing round
of the night
it's gonna ops for some quick
development here let's just break the
pin you break the pin or h6 and just
break the pin so I'm expecting and
eventually six of course to open up the
dark square Bishop mm-hmm castles or hmm
castles h3 give the knight a kick now
I'm not sure this one could be
vulnerable let's let's start with this
if they put pressure on it with Knight
d7 maybe then I commit okay no so I have
the Bishop air pressure on the knight
got a recapture and I have rook e1 to
defend this pawn so how do I really put
this to use having the bishop here I
could give the night a kick butt on
night before I'm not sure what I would
do hmm because then d3 is weakened maybe
a three and then c4 hmm I'd like to get
my knight to this e4 square but there's
gonna be some fire on this pawn really
soon
there should be for an f4 I don't know
about that I weakened my diagonal let's
start with a3 preparing to kick the
night and I have to worry about night
before and probably Queenie - lets go
Queenie - if it's it again I'll play
rook e1 because I have to and I have c4
I wonder if b4 is an idea on b4 maybe
well I don't know
- I have too many options huh a
voluntary retreat so Knight g6 I guess
is the idea let's do this first night g6
I back up and also I like the idea that
even if at some point they have more
pressure on this pawn when they take it
there in a pin although they do have an
option to take my bishop with check to
get out of it hmm that's interesting
probably just Knight c3 this is a weak
square but they have the dark square
Bishop around this night could be
misplaced
h4 h5 can be an idea he could turn out
to be out of play if I'm not careful
like h4 h5 I don't know how great a move
that is a great an idea because Knight
isse Evan into f5 should be pretty good
nothing wrong with that black has a
perfectly healthy structure nice harmony
between the structure in the remaining
Bishop so hmm
let's just get a quick move in get the
rook on a good square with only this one
open file it's quite it's not a far
stretch to think both sets of rooks will
be exchanged hmm I wonder Knight e4 they
will take that pawn hmm really stuck for
a plan here hmm not sure to do this d5
square bit tricky a4 there's a Bishop b4
let's make some room for my king I don't
know how great that is okay alright if
they take with the Queen maybe I could
reposition my knight this is the one
moment where there isn't pressure on
this pawn so let's go in for this maybe
97
Bishop takes pawn takes I'll have a
passed pawn and I'll be playing with the
bishop pair f4 might be sensitive knight
on d5 they're coordinating an f4 hmm
this is enough protected pond so 95 c4
Knight f4 I could play Queen III hitting
the knight end the a7 pawn
ooh that's a very mysterious move I
think I should just run right in and
give the check or actually let's hold
off there's no rush with that this
Bishop is in a defensive position so
let's keep this address of position of
for my knight maybe even c5 and then
Knight in here if I have enough support
for b4 c5 I do give up this square but
when my pawn arrives on d6 it'll be a
connected past pawn mm-hm if this pawn
has ever challenged that can't be good
opening up a diagonal straight towards
the king I have two bishops pointing
right at the king ooh and just as I say
that they do do that move okay pawn
takes I guess Wow
this pawn is unprotected there must be
some tactical shot here uh-huh well
maybe push no I don't want to give that
pawn out maybe hmm
let's make a non-committal move I'm
running in Reverse here with that move
but I don't want to give this square up
so easily let's do this maybe break down
they're light squares right put this
unopposed Bishop to work let his
presence be felt hmm they're ready to
win that on all right let's give it a
kick
hmm okay let's go right here actually
the queen is unprotected and I think
that wins the game hmm
I was ready to play 2d3 I'm glad I
thought of moving one additional rank
you know that I'm gonna win this pawn
now there's no Knight f4 I take I have
some concern though of a position where
I'm up upon but it may be opposite color
bishops but I have a safe King and okay
take with the or take with the knight
first and let's recapture with the
bishop and maybe continue pushing yeah
let's still crack open the light squares
remove this pawn pawn push I advance
let's still take with the bishop Queen
check incoming let's throw a check oh I
didn't see that in let's keep the Queen
on board less than 10 seconds mm-hmm
yeah tough to get this guy working I
don't know if my queen and bishop alone
are enough to really cause him a problem
the Queen might be a very good defender
okay I think I have to take him out so
okay here's the plan I'm going to
reroute my bishop to I guess II four
actually and if I could pick up this
pawn off as a colored Bishop ending
maybe not such a big deal you know let's
go here it's Novak rank mates just
trying to get Bishop b4 on the longest
diagonal and I will think about picking
up this pawn I'm gonna take this guy
actually I don't want that pawn to be a
thorn I know these are very ugly pawns
but um yeah let's avoid the Queen
exchange or I could have gone in for
that I don't know hmm let's grab the
I almost lost on time how didn't I lose
on time actually with that move
I was way too close okay and let's come
right here
clean h2 it's jus there's just a couple
checks I got Queen c6 mate as a threat
how do they defend that let's see ooh
wow they lost in time and that's usually
a screen that I see yikes I probably
should have lost on time I saw the one
after that one move I think it read 2.0
Wow okay yeah let me before I dive in
with a stock fish on this one I wonder
about this position right here this
middlegame position I don't know that
I'm really any better at this point here
this was I spent some time here and I'm
just I don't know it's it's an improving
move h3 but you know if I'm to me if I
can move if I could take two turns
around I don't even know what my next
move would be you know it's it's easy to
see what my reply is going to be here
just recapturing but if if black
maintain the tension and say well I
don't know made a king move I'm not sure
what I would do here this is because as
mentioned this is a really good
structure nothing wrong with black
structure they have a nice grip over d5
I think I could have played better I
don't think that this is a good position
really it's not it's not worse but I
don't know it van if there's a
significant advantage for white here so
we'll see where there's a suggestion
maybe maybe I should have inserted c4
first I don't know
I had to react a little bit to this pawn
hmm I don't know when they lashed out
with f6 plant the plan started to be
clear well there were there were targets
with the e6 but I think they're in a
tough spot here because how do they make
how do they make progress this earlier
mentioned idea of 97 into f5 that's out
I've controlled the d5 square mm-hmm
we'll see where the suggestions are for
both sides I'm not quite sure I think it
I got to a position that wasn't really
favorable but we'll check it out and see
what stockfish has to say on this one
okay let's see where there's an
improvement here at this opening I don't
like going for the four pounds attack c4
and then f4 it's not bad but it's not
really my style mmm your centers gonna
come under some heavy fire I'm not
really too familiar with this opening
but uh let's let's see if we could take
something away from this it's suggesting
a capture on d6
mm-hmm this is the first moment where it
suggests to capture on d6 correct Bishop
e2 there isn't a problem in c6 hmm c4 is
popping up so c4 capturing on d6 well
here's one thing capturing on d6 I mean
what ended up happening in the game
there was some fire placed on the e5
pawn and I was having to defend
many of my moves were reactions to the
pressure on e5 right Queeny to to defend
the pawn rook to e1 eventually Bishop f4
anticipating Knight g6 so my opponent
was giving quite a bit of direction to
my playing to my moves
due to the pressure on e5 just trying to
reason out like some of the differences
you know maintaining upon on e5 or
capturing on d6
okay so let's actually carry this out
just for a few
suggest the capture with nh3 or even c4
so okay playing within this structure h3
takes I think most human players would
maintain the tension though let's say c4
Knight b6 this seems like a pretty
common move though I know the computer
suggesting I'd be six but suppose Knight
f6 they have Queen b3 mean B three Queen
b6 Queen e3 oh it's really getting
computer issue Bishop e7 g4y Ike's
Knight c3 I'm not really a big fan of
this type of weakening to the Kings side
but okay well it's it's another
structure to certainly be familiar with
the capture on d6 and you don't have to
well I won't be tethered to the defense
of the e5 pawn okay oh yeah I'm already
liking that idea you know just so it's I
could go with a smoother development and
yeah there isn't that target enough to
babysit the e5 pawn alright I castled
chop-chop playing with the bishop hair
so this is another direction to go in
and they want to go c4 right away hmm
this was my fear c4 Knight before and
some invasion on these squares I saw the
Queen exchange I know I could kick the
King around but doesn't this kind of
peter out isn't that a fine home hmm as
a pawn advantage playing with the bishop
pair I guess this is no longer an issue
huh okay so I guess I have the advantage
due to this pawn and bishop pair I don't
know how great a strength is pawn on e5
is to be perfectly honest Bishop e7
let's just take it out a few more then
that gets a kick ooh night c2 I don't I
don't see many human players playing
that I think there would be a great fear
of it being trapped computer must have
something timely
rook be one rook da capture capture okay
so he could run away just in time but
Bishop b4 hitting the knight grabbing on
h7 hmm interesting
yeah I did see that I could go in for
the Queen exchange but I guess I was too
fearful of a knight C to move but the
simple Knight c3 development and it's
just a one move threat when it does hit
92 okay so I could have played c4 I
could have saved myself some time a
tempo not played a3 and it would have
been a completely different ball game
right playing mm playing it in game all
of a sudden or I don't know what you
would call it may be a queenless in the
middle game but anyhow the Queen's would
be off played a three Queen e2 yeah so I
have some defensive duties now I didn't
even consider popped up for a moment b3
I guess with Bishop b2 as the idea I
didn't even consider that Knight d2 is
another move oh I don't even consider
this one either I played Bishop here and
then back Knight d2 and a knight g6
there's Knight c4 and suppose b5 Knight
d6 going in for a sack huh yeah computer
computer nosov pair yeah computer has no
fear of giving up a pawn but I'd be a
little bit concerned not really the type
to invest some material but okay
different ideas present that I didn't
even consider here a knight on c4 Bishop
on b2 it's pretty locked into Bishop f4
okay not much of an advantage really
nice e3 doesn't like rook there Bishop H
Bishop h5 yeah yeah I didn't like this
position already in Bishop h5 I'm not
really a fan of that I mean was it doing
I don't know I would never really want
to even take the night just helps out
the rook on the h-file yeah so probably
c4 earlier instead of a three are the
are the different ideas I would probably
employ in a future game c4 at this point
excuse me after you six c4 at this point
or playing the position where I don't
even have the e5 pawn just capturing on
d6 so once I'm here I really not just
I'm not a fan of the white side at all
not worse but it's tough to really
suggest good moves here 94-94 I thought
I could take here Knight d2 could take
here with check I guess the queen is
coming under some fire huh Bishop d6
rook takes rook takes Queen e5 hmm yeah
that's a pretty interesting variation
there okay useful move flight Square
rooks are off now yeah still pretty even
yeah this was a mysterious move Queen
this Queen to f8 tough to wrap my head
around that move suggests in 97 you know
tough tough game here okay that's that's
a game loser the f5 advance +2 now let's
see how I could have followed up Feder
it's calling for C 5 C 595 on Bishop
takes I guess I just capture and then
crash through on e6 +3 oh yeah these
bishops are monsters takes takes takes
and you can't block because that's mate
hmm so what would happen Queen takes
pawn king here Queen f6 and okay just
cleaning house okay I retreated
vest and then b4 he likes the b4 move
okay and then c5 and then fortunately I
did see that Queen c-4 move it wasn't I
didn't calculate this c4 or Knight here
I was thinking about playing Queen to d3
but the most forward move Queen c4 and
that's going to be at Queen's in a pin
was the advantage over lost from here
just just have a close eye on the
evaluation looking for any big shifts I
don't think so
it likes Queen g8 the only thing I have
to be a little bit concerned about as
mentioned is the opposite color Bishop
ending I mean it is an opposite color
Bishop ending but not a true one where
it's just those pieces still the Queen's
on board yeah it takes I'd actually like
I'm a little bit curious about this
ending
I played Queen c4 and right around here
I think I was really close to losing on
time but I wonder about this ending here
something certainly lost yeah I mean
it's still tricky I have to passed pawns
in their responds these F pawns and the
e pawn negate one another so I'm just
kind of visualizing this where it's just
an H upon a BH versus a and actually
here's another thing let me yeah I don't
have this Bishop he can sacrifice
himself for one of these two you know
like something like this I have to be
careful of this take stakes and if this
King gets over here really quick the
bishop can sacrifice himself are not
yeah that's still not the exact case
because these pawns will still play a
role initially it seems like they cancel
out one another but with this idea of
one day sacrificing the bishop for the a
pond and me not having the correct color
to escort while me not having the
correct color Bishop to successfully
escort this pawn to promotion these
pawns will these will play a role and
sacrificing the bishop for that pond you
can't do it so quickly now I guess it
still is the correct idea to maintain
the Queen's on the board to really
highlight the fact that black has the
more vulnerable King so just from that
general principle this having the safer
King I know this isn't a very happy
looking structure for the white king but
it's certainly better than black who has
no pawns around so Queen c4 take now and
the right and well at this final
position they lost on time but what
would have been good Queen g5 king h1 I
would have probably played here I guess
it's still fight oh this is getting into
a queen exchange and I'm not sure how to
trust the evaluation to be perfectly
honest I know it's saying about a pound
and a half with Queen b5
but hmm I don't know it could turn out
where it's a holdable you know it's it's
holdable to a draw I can't be certain on
that he likes king h1 with a +2
advantage keeping the Queens on board
Queen b5 Queen d4 King c7 and then
picking up the a pond ya have to be a
little careful if Queen f1 mate but yeah
I lost on time in this position here
would have been certainly interesting if
the game still went on here but uh yeah
some things that I'm taking away or just
these different ideas regarding the
structure playing within a different
structure here to capture on d6 would be
good to get some games under my belts
out of this out of this structure get
some experience with it and also going
straight in for one of my favorites the
Queen exchange and not having so much
fear of night c2 it's
easily parried with night a developing
move it's now I'm not inconvenienced at
all
and I'm playing this position with the
bishop hair and yeah this night could
maybe be sidelined even at some point if
he was ever kicked and going back here I
don't know just make a passing move if
he ever goes in this direction this
could be quite uncomfortable for the
night but out yeah the two things
playing within a different structure and
going in for this Queen exchange idea
are things to note for me at least but
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below to
this video and I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you